hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my Doctor Who episode 5 video
we finally found out who Maisie Williams
is playing we find out why the doctors
face looks exactly like the character
that Capaldi played during series 4 and
the fires of Pompeii and I think they're
laying seeds for something really
special to happen later on if the
opportunity presents itself so let's get
going just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet a new round
of the Doctor Who giveaway starts now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so let's start with top 5 just you
know biggest one first meet Maisie
Williams playing a shield err not a Time
Lord but functionally immortal by the
end of the episode I am sure this will
totally not end badly the reason why
this is so exciting you know not only
because of that weird look that she has
at the end because that montage is
happening she slowly comes to the
realization of this like new philosophy
that presumably we'll find out about in
the next episode technically it's not a
two-parter but because her story is
carrying into the next episode I'm
thinking of it as a two-parter there
were so many things that were being
teased about her character just like the
offhanded dialogue that the doctor had
premonitions just remembering in the
wrong direction you start to get the
idea that she's having this sort of
River Song type arc where like she's
remembering things in the wrong
direction like River Song in the doctors
timelines move in opposite directions
but really it just leads into the idea
of her becoming immortal in the cyclical
nature of time like you know of events
repeating themselves over large periods
of time and you have to appreciate the
way they weave that in really nicely
with the idea of storytelling like the
roles that stories play in mythic
culture Maisy's character explains she
makes puppets to make up stories when
people go away to hopefully bring them
back to try and change the story tell a
story to bring a favorable outcome
that's something that people still do
today but because this is Doctor Who in
the way doctor who plays with
reincarnation regeneration you think
that there's like some weird aspect to
this like maybe she has magical powers
of some kind
now that turns out to not be the case
really the only special ability she has
now is that that chip will never stop
repairing her body which kind of makes
it like Dalek technology although it's
from the Maya so hopefully she's not
gonna wind up looking like the Daleks in
this sewer here or like the face of BOE
like where she just keeps going on and
on and on until something really
terrible happens to her body but she
can't die
the doctor has that speech at the end
mostly to explain why he gave the second
chip to her you know so that she could
have a companion of her own but it also
sounds a little sinister to living
forever is more of a curse than it is a
blessing like maybe in helping her he
actually made things worse but on the
number-four though meet the Maya doctor
whose newest race of monsters
if the Odin character looked familiar
it's because he looks a lot like Bryan
blessed from flash he played like the
prince of the Valkyries there were a lot
of funny in jokes in this too especially
the Benny Hill stuff all it needed was a
Benny Hill theme and then they actually
played the Benny Hill theme in the
episode that was even funnier to me but
as it's explained in the episode their
race just goes around strafing cultures
trying to extract chemicals from the
finest warriors but in a funny way they
do the exact same thing that Maisie
Williams character does they tell a
story to try and bring a favorable
outcome they're just play-acting
something specific to that Viking
culture so if they went to another
planet that Odin character would co-op
some character from from that other
races culture did anybody else think of
Anthony Hopkins version of Odin in the
Thor movies whenever the doctor was
making the joke about the yo-yo see look
at him he can't be Odin he doesn't even
have a yo-yo
somebody tell Kevin Feige and Marvel
that they've been leaving the yo-yo bits
out of the Thor movies on the number
three though babies are the finest poets
on Doctor Who of course the doctor
speaks baby
no surprise there and of course the baby
is like the most eloquent poetic person
in the narrative that's a very
philosophical doctor type moment where
the doctor waxes on on how the most
innocent things can be the most
beautiful things babies are pure because
they haven't been corrupted yet that
that's a very common theme across a lot
of literature like children are the most
intelligent people but on the number two
the doctor remembers why he chose this
face huge huge revealed that I felt like
it was very important it's gonna go down
as a very important moment in Capaldi's
run you know however long it goes on but
I don't like the way they used it I was
really kind of hoping that he would have
chosen this face as part of this
prophecy of the hybrid or you know some
much more complex part of the plotline
but it turns out to be this really
general thing like I'm the doctor and I
save people really the writers could
have used any small moment to make the
doctor realize that you guys can let me
know in the comments though do you feel
like they wasted the mystery of the
doctors face on this
very generic type of reveal it's a
really great character moment for the
doctor I just I feel like the face
reveal was a missed opportunity they
they could have used it for something
even bigger finally on to my number one
WTF moment Maisie Williams becomes a
hybrid here's the really important thing
about this that we need to talk about
does this have anything to do with
Davros as prophecy of the hybrid there
was a prophecy on Gallifrey that Davros
referred to maybe Maisie Williams is
that hybrid I feel like that would be
amazing because the doctor made it sound
like this prophecy is the most terrible
thing ever like this hybrid must never
come to exist hybrid Maisie Williams
also works with the metaphor to back in
the Davros episodes Missy said each of
us is a hybrid she was speaking about
the balance between enemies and friends
like the hybrid between an enemy and a
friend but I do feel like even if you
haven't been completely satisfied with
the the Doctor Who stories in series 9
they've done a really good job of
presenting this hybrid theme across all
the episodes so we still have 7 episodes
left not including the Christmas special
we need to see like how this hybrid
theme spreads across the rest of the
season but here's another big question
for you guys like what did you think
about the way they use previous Doctor
Who ideas in this episode but did you
enjoy seeing David Tennant and all his
companions it's always fun to see them
use clips from old episodes they've used
a lot of audio from classic ooh and now
they used a lot of video from new who
episodes
use sparingly can be really awesome I
think if they do it too much like if
they do this every single episode then
it'll get a little bit old but the big
thing to walk away from this episode is
is in wondering if the doctor created a
tidal wave change in time you know he
said it's okay to make ripples but we're
time travelers we can't make waves so
I'm just gonna move into Easter eggs now
if there are any that you guys see that
that I don't end up mentioning just
write them below in the comments the
2000 year old diary comes out now the
second doctor had a diary but it was
only like a 500 year old diary so
they're just like slowly upgrading it
hopefully we'll see a 3,000 year old
diary at some point I mean I'd like to
believe dr. who can last that long good
man goes to war was the first time we
heard the doctor speak baby that was
Matt Smith's doctor which was funny
because everyone called him the baby
doctor because he was so young
the doctor says reverse the polarity of
the neutron flow right out of the third
doctor there's been so much Capaldi
that's gone back to the third doctor so
many references to the first three
doctors just in Gen
roll and there's actually been a bunch
of episode so the doctors gotten into
sword fights there's Sea Devils the mask
of mandragora the androids of Terra and
the Kings demons I really liked the nod
that he gave to Clara when she raised
her hand to like oh yeah you've been
traveling with me of course you use the
sword at some point one of the most fun
things about Doctor Who is the
adventures that we don't see like when
they opened the episode they were
talking about saving the falow seein's
that's a whole adventure that we'll
probably never see like you just have to
conjure things up in your imagination as
they talk about them I guess that's
really where like the Big Finish stuff
comes in where the audio dramas come in
to fill those gaps speaking of which I
think I may have mentioned it in my last
Doctor Who video but just in case I
didn't they're actually making audio
dramas for the war dr. John Hurt's war
doctor so if he ever wanted to hear a
bunch of war doctor stories like
full-blown stories they're going to be
making that boxset real soon so don't
forget next week kind of part 2 of this
episode technically it's not a
two-parter but Maisie Williams is back
playing the same character and it's like
a continuation of this story so be sure
to subscribe to get that video and that
reminds me congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner pancake power you
win a $20 Amazon gift card just be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so I can get your contact
info in slightly related news there's
actually been a bunch of Game of Thrones
news the last day or so so I might do
that video next and then do my flash
arrow Q&A so just stay tuned for all
that stuff while you guys wait you can
click here for all my Doctor Who series
9 videos in case you missed it I
actually posted the Game of Thrones New
York Comic Con panel from last week you
can click here to watch that thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tide